you inspired me with great inspiration I
went on Letterman and I danced on his
desk I'm full drag and showed him my
boobs when you did that was that
calculated did you know it wasn't so
spontaneous I mean you can see me up
there as if I am on a train that I don't
know where it's going right and and
after you do something like that is it
like slow motion you're you're sitting
and talking today completely outer body
it was Dave's birthday yeah and you said
hey Dave for your birthday which is
great moment of inspiration on talk
shows cuz it's hard to really make those
things fly yeah so you were you're
having fun
yeah jump up on the desk and you you
pick up your top and you give Dave a
topless dance I mean
[Applause]
I did this like funny little strip dance
with my friend in the Lower East Village
his producers got ahold of the
information again this is before
internet and you know that how people
found out anything at that point was a
mystery but I was like yeah and he was
like you know can we talk about that on
the show and I was like just sure great
and so it just started I don't know it
was just a runaway train it evolved now
it when you're doing it do you know it's
gonna become one whenever it's a classic
Letterman thing they show it they showed
it every year if there was ever a
compilation video after you do it are
there people like your managers and some
go you just [ __ ] up royally I don't
want that [ __ ] around me I really don't
know why don't you team what could
happen with the team they stud but you
start to doubt your own instincts no I
just I've got too many of my own but I
want smart people to bounce stuff off of
and I've never been like a please hold
my hand right I really I want to do
things together I want to be a leader
and you would think you of all people
would want to be surrounded by those
people because you didn't have a mother
and father
those people would stand inside like a
Hollywood publicist wasn't gonna
fulfilling the mother wrong right
well that's true by the Hollywood
publish this does help you get work
sometimes they're in the right party and
they mention your name and you know I
like to take it all into my own control
when you did the Letterman appearance
don't you get off and go oh my god I
just killed it I know I got off and I
was like holy [ __ ] what did I just do
and when I watched it that night with my
friends as I talked about in that
chapter no I was like okay that was
crazy fun I think the tone came off okay
thank God David Letterman didn't make me
look bad in front of people he could
have sent me into a real bad place with
disapproval in that moment and instead
he was charming and cute and let
everybody know this was okay and and it
was okay and we got away with it and and
and that night I said to myself okay so
next chapter you need to go and become a
young lady and
you're still a teenager and so this is
okay but you're about to be 20 and now I
think that was the cap to your teens
what do you want your twenties to be and
I immediately went out and I'm I know it
was when I found ever after I found the
path that I wanted to be on achieving
that led to the path because I said
that's the closing of a wild chapter it
was the closing of a chapter this ended
wow that's unbelievable to me I was like
a little less this a little more that